bonjour alexis poulain merci de répondre
à nos questions sur arte france eric
dupond moretti qui s'est dit ce matin à
son arrivée à la cjr je cite serein et
particulièrement déterminé un ministre
de la justice n'est pas au dessus des
lois mais il n'est pas en dessous non
plus c'est ce qu'il a dit peut-il
va-t-il doit-il être mis en examen avec
ses poulains ont cessé les juges qui
vont le décidé cette cour de justice de
la république qui a déjà travaillé sur
le dossier
c'est aussi une façon de pêcher 1 le
ministre de continuer dans ses fonctions
françois bayrou n'avait pas pu devenir
ministre rappelez-vous pour les
histoires des emplois fictifs au
parlement européen jean jacques urvoas
aussi avait été obligé de s'arrêter là
on a l'impression que même si eric
dupond moretti est placé sous le statut
de témoin assisté ou mis en examen et
bien il a la confiance du chef de l'état
qui aurait dit que même la justice n'est
pas un pouvoir mais une autorité et
qu'elle n'a pas à être un pouvoir donc
qui renverrait dans les cordes cette
cour de justice de la république et qui
maintiendrait la confiance à ce ministre
controversée puisque le voilà dans des
affaires de règlements de comptes entre
magistrats lui même qui était avocat
qu'est ce que ça dit tout simplement
bien que c'est encore une grave erreur
de casting de la part des modèles macron
d'avoir pris cet avocat emblématique
célèbre pour le mettre à la tête de
l'institution judiciaire alors même
qu'il avait déjà de nombreux contentieux
des histoires passées présentes avec
d'autres avocats des juges des
magistrats
et voilà le marais dans lequel on se
retrouve qui ne fait pas de bien bien
entendu à l'image du politique à l'image
aussi d'un état qui semble bien bien mal
en point
compte tenu de ces nominations de ces
erreurs de casting ou le mélange des
genres de conflit d'intérêts à la devenu
quasiment la règle depuis qu emmanuel
macron est devenu président de la
république
mais s'il est mis en examen eric dupond
moretti
qu'est-ce que ça va changer pour la fin
du quinquennat d'emmanuel macro estime
être fragilisés emmanuel macron qui a
défendu hier le droit de son ministre à
la présomption d'innocence quand même
hein
alex poulain bien sûr il ya il ya la
présomption d'innocence et il ya une
cour de justice de la république qui est
très lente dans l' affaire karachi par
exemple pour edouard balladur il a fallu
trente ans pour arriver à une solution
c'est de cour de justice elle est quand
même assez décrié que ce soit christine
lagarde également dans l' affaire tapie
qui n'a quasiment eu aucune condamnation
alors même qu'il y avait eu de graves
négligences de la part de madame lagarde
dans le dossier tapie
là c'est à peu près la même chose
c'est-à-dire que si on a un ministre de
la justice mis en examen est bien dans
le gouvernement des macros c'est pas si
grave
voilà ce qu'on continue circulez ya rien
à voir c'est quand même fondamental
on ne peut pas accepter ça en tant que
citoyens d'avoir un ministre mis en
examen et en exercice ministre de la
justice qui plus est ce serait un
précédent très grave ce serait aussi
l'aveu finalement de ce gouvernement du
confit d'intérêt où tant de ministres
ont déjà été mis en examen que ce soit
gérald darmanin dans une plainte pour
viol mais aussi certains qui ont
quasiment échappé en espagne r une hache
et qui avait fait travailler son
conjoint qui a fait grâce à une
pirouette éviter le pire alexis colère
secrétaire général de l'elysée lui aussi
pris dans une affaire de conflit
d'intérêts
richard ferrand bien sûr au perchoir de
l'assemblée nationale avec les mutuel de
bretagne les affaires s'accumulent on a
l'impression que c'est la norme
finalement et puis on se désole enfin la
classe politique se désole que les
citoyens n'avaient plus voter ce détour
d'une classe politique qu'il juge
finalement corrompus ou pas du tout à la
hauteur de la tâche qui est la leur on
parle beaucoup de droits et devoirs en
ce moment avec cette vaccination
quasiment obligatoire et bien est-ce que
ce serait pas le devoir de ministre de
la justice de démissionner s'il est mis
en examen ou placé sous le statut de
témoin assisté simplement par décence
parce que c'est ainsi que irait mieux la
république or on a un président qui est
derrière lui qui le soutient et qui fera
tout pour que la justice ne soit pas un
pouvoir et que donc ce quinquennat se
termine sur des béquilles 1 comme il a
commencé quasiment avec une difficulté
bien sûr d'image pour le ministre qui
aura bien du mal à faire avancer
quelques dossiers que ce soit vous avez
évoqué le cas françois perrot qui
n'avait donc pas pu
prendre la chancellerie vous avez parlé
également de jean jacques urvoas qui a
été mis en examen il ya aussi les
prédécesseur d'eric dupond-moretti donc
jean jacques urvoas ou nicole belloubet
christiane taubira également qui ont eu
des problèmes avec la justice avec ce
ministère est ce qu'il ya pas un
problème finalement avec la chancellerie
place vendôme
alors oui il ya clairement un problème
c'est d'abord le problème de la
séparation des pouvoirs parce que la
vème république permet cette porosité
permet au président de mettre le nez
dans les affaires on a vu aussi c'est
cette façon dont la justice peut être
utilisé de manière politique
ce soit pour mettre des épées de
damoclès au-dessus de d'opposants ou
salir des opposants la façon dont la
sphère sarkozy les fadettes pose
question sur le la sphère des écoutes
sur le parquet national financiers il y
a une vraie question d'éthique sur les
coudes des avocats alors même que le
secret professionnel ne devrait pas
permettre ça mais grâce à une
manipulation de quelques jours on a pu
mettre sur écoute des avocats qui
n'aurait pas dû être sur écoute donc il
ya quelque chose de profondément pour
iwuy royaume de danemark mais en
république française dans la façon dont
sont organisés les pouvoirs et les
contre-pouvoirs et particulièrement le
ministère de la justice parce qu'on voit
bien qu'il ya une guerre larvée depuis
des années entre les magistrats les
avocats le parquet et les politiques qui
souhaiteraient bien faire avancer des
affaires ou les faire reculer
emmanuel macron ne serait pas devenu
président de la république s'il n'y
avait pas eu la sphère fillon lors de la
campagne de 2017
et cette affaire est arrivé au bon
moment avec une rapidité extrême
c'était vraiment surprenant de voir la
façon dont cette affaire a pu comme ça
émerger dans la campagne donc il ya un
vrai problème profond sur la façon dont
la justice est rendue en france et sur
l'indépendance de la justice et sur les
moyens également de du ministère de la
justice les moyens d'aider cour de
justice en france aleris allons
rapidement dernière question rapidement
à alexis poulain la corne de jeu
la république seule instance donc
habilitée à juger des ministres réputée
pour sa lenteur vous l'avez dit mais
cette fois elle va vite pourquoi selon
vous est-ce que c'est politique
on sait qu'il ya une mammut chou députés
allait re aiment et antoine savignat
députés aient l'air qui équipe la cjr
pour ne pas prendre part je cite un
semblant de justice
oui alors c'est pas un semblant de
justice c'est clairement sur la cjr
alors déjà la façon dont elle est
composée allie à la fois des députés des
élus et des magistrats
le parquet national également est là
mais la question qui se pose c'est le
règlement de compte entre 1 eric
dupond-moretti lorsqu'il était avocat et
des magistrats qui ont déjà eu à se
quereller qui ont des histoires passées
et qui l'avons laver leur linge sale
quasiment public alors non c'est fermé
puisque c'est la cour de justice de la
république mais ça pose évidemment
question mais ça pose la question que je
j'évoquais tout à l'heure celle du
casting pourquoi avoir choisi eric
dupond moretti
sachant pertinemment que c'est ce qui
allait arriver c'est cette question
qu'il faut poser au président emmanuel
macron pourquoi avoir ce fait ce choix
si ce n'est pour attaquer l'institution
judiciaire mettre le doigt là où ça fait
mal et dire voilà ça ne peut pas marcher
si on prend quelqu'un qui vient du
sérail ça ne peut pas marcher
donc évidemment sur la cjr il ya une
vraie question puis il ya la question
bien sûr bla la justice à deux trois
vitesses
que vous soyez riche ou puissant et bien
vous n'aurez pas à faire à la même
justice là en l'occurrence la lenteur de
la cjr la façon dont son prix les
délibérés permet aussi de penser qu' il
y a un peu d'arrangements dans la façon
dont les ministres sont traités alors
que leurs collaborateurs eux sont jugés
devant des cours de droit commun donc ça
pose vraiment question il était même
question des normes de certains
programmes d'élections présidentielles
passées de supprimer tout simplement
cette cour de justice de la république
peut-être que ça va revenir sur le
dauphin est bloqué à l'époque
effectivement merci beaucoup à l'ex
époux loin d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
éditorialistes